mossoul deuxième ville d'irak située
près de la ville biblique de ninive en
haute mésopotamie a été ravagée depuis
sa capture par des chants 2014
la vieille ville est presque entièrement
détruite les chrétiens persécutés ont
pris la fuite
il y a quatre églises chrétiennes de
différents rites autour de cette place
aujourd'hui en ruines
autrefois des enfants y jouer les gens
allaient au marché ou bien s'y installer
pour discuter mossoul était au coeur de
la plus ancienne des communautés des
églises d'orient qui n'a fait que
s'affaiblir depuis 2003 l'unesco a
commencé la reconstruction que l'évêque
de mossoul vient visiter ya actuellement
à peu près en 350 à 400 milles 10 ont
grosso modo à un demi million de
personnes un corps qui reste éparpillé
un peu dans la plaine de ninive et dans
le kurdistan irakien où ils les ont
accueillis de manière extraordinaire
ils étaient plus d'un million en 2003 la
plupart des chrétiens de mossoul se sont
réfugiés à erbil capitale du kurdistan
irakien
c'est là que s'est réfugié là il a avec
sa fille mariam dans le quartier
chrétien tu as une kawa je n'ai aucune
confiance en ce pays
j'ai 42 ans et je n'ai vu que la guerre
les sanctions la famine les abus des
chrétiens ciblées et tués et puis l'état
islamique
nous n'avons pas d'avenir ici nous
n'avons plus rien pas question de
retourner à mossoul
mes voisins que je respecte ont pillé ma
maison leïla a perdu toute confiance la
tolérance le respect entre communautés
musulmane et chrétienne ne sont plus là
c'est l'heure de la messe le taxi les
attend
il n'y aura bientôt plus de chrétiens en
irak croit leila ceux qui peuvent partir
le front et l'oci s'il en avait les
moyens
l'église est gardé par les peshmergas
les combattants kurdes
c'est ce que nous faisons depuis 2004
dit cet officier le père ni à des
sabines habib s'apprête à célébrer la
messe à l'église reine de la paix
rétablir la confiance ne sera pas facile
et il faudra beaucoup de patience
ses fidèles ont tout perdu à mossoul il
leur demande de prier pour le pape
les préparatifs vont bon train pour
cette visite historique dans un pays
encore aux prises avec la violence et
les attaques à l'explosif des milices
chiites rebelles ces images des réfugiés
de mossoul ont été tournées par la
journaliste perrine juin
la plupart des chrétiens que j'ai
rencontrés disent que à bagdad et
mossoul il se sentait harcelé il était
perpétuellement menacé il ne se sentait
pas à l'aise et donc c'est pour ça
depuis qu'ils sont arrivés à erbil 60
beaucoup plus libre la plupart sont
installés même dans le quartier chrétien
de derby line kawa et donc c'est en tout
cas ce qu'ils rapportent c'est qu'ils se
sentent beaucoup plus libres 2 ou en
tout cas la question de la religion à
moins d'importance en tout cas comme
kaka mossoul et bagdad par exemple chez
chrétiens dachier au kurdistan
voudraient que le pape dise au monde
entier j'imagine qu'ils attendent du du
pape celle ce sont des paroles fortes et
aussi une reconnaissance de cette
souffrance et de cette persécution
depuis des décennies mais ils attendent
aussi du pape fall aquila est non
seulement à la rencontre des chrétiens
mais aussi de tout le peuple irakien et
pour reconnaître cette souffrance et ses
années de violence et de guerre
c'est à erbil que le pape terminera son
périple dimanche après s'être rendu à
bagdad et nadjaf pour rencontrer les
dirigeants politiques et religieux
musulman irakiens ainsi que dans les
régions chrétiennes de mossoul et car à
gauche
[Musique]